andrea how are you
should i say i'm fine and then you'll
say you're fine and then we'll pretend
like we're both fine
[Laughter]
so actually you know um you and i have
known each other a bunch of years
and you have been a confidant and a
coach to me
for a while um and uh
i wanted to share some of the way you
view the world with other people
and instead of like interviewing you um
because i find that sort of rather
distant
um i thought i'd actually just ask you
some real questions
um and and sort of take the risk to let
people
hear it all
so here's what i'm dealing with uh so at
the beginning of kovid
i called a friend of mine in the
military and i asked him
how do you compartmentalize your
emotions because
i knew that we were dealing with trauma
and i wanted to be mission focused and
pivot my business but at the same time
there was this trauma of kovid
and i know that in combat they're able
to compartmentalize their emotions so
they can stay focused at the mission at
hand
and he gave me a very stern warning he
basically said you can't
compartmentalize your emotions not for
any length of time he says we can do it
for a short period of time
in in battle he says but you're going to
deal with it at some point you're
dealing with trauma there's no avoiding
trauma
and he says sometimes you know we we
often deal with it
months after we get home so i took that
warning
to heart and i called all of my a-type
personality friends and
gave them the warning that we're not
avoiding this we're delaying this
and uh it's been what we're now four or
five months in something like that and
uh i know that he sometimes starts to
feel the effects
about four or five months after and i'm
actually right on schedule weirdly
i'm starting to feel it now and so i
called him the other day
and i didn't was there's no leading the
witness i didn't say what i was going
through i didn't say what i was
experiencing i
i asked i started with a very open-ended
question i asked
what are your symptoms when you come
back from combat
and he said one of his symptoms is that
his sleep schedule gets disrupted so he
starts going to bed really late for no
reason
and then in the morning he doesn't want
to get out of bed and i'm like check
and then he says he has one day where
he's totally unproductive and
unmotivated and he says to himself well
that's okay
i needed a break anyway i need to relax
but then he has another and another
and another and i'm like check
and then he said um and he doesn't want
to spend time
talking to people with people and i was
like
check and i'm coming to terms with the
fact that you know
four months in i'm now starting to deal
with it and i am not myself
um and i you know when other people ask
me for advice how to deal with this i'm
good at dispensing the advice i'm not
necessarily
trying to follow it i am calling people
like you and i are having this
conversation now
but i'm very curious you know
do i just have to sit in this can i
expedite it how do i manage it
like what is this and how do i get
through it you know somebody asked me
are you depressed
and i don't know how to answer that
question is that a clinical diagnosis
i'm i'm off my game
so help me make sense of this
sure so let's start with how are you
like how are you feeling what
what are you feeling uh
like i said i know i'm not myself
um i'm you know motivation comes and
goes sometimes
in a day you know um
uh you know feeling alone but not lonely
so the difference for me is like i'm
i get the i thank goodness i have my
family that has absolutely helped keep
me sane
but i definitely notice the effects of
being single
like and i've gone long periods being
single before and it's just like
whatever you know
but now like what am i supposed to do
with this right no
i don't even know how to and i'm not
that motivated to go meet somebody
either
yeah and it's really hard complicated
right now right
okay so um one of the things i noticed
about how you just explained how you
were feeling is you actually didn't tell
me
any feelings you told me
your behaviors you told me you did say
one thing that you weren't lonely
you were not one emotion you weren't
feeling that and so
you know i think one of the first steps
to understanding how we work with these
things is to first be able to name it
so we have these like handy little
sheets
because you're essentially learning a
new language most of us as kids like we
never really learned how to
name our emotions or work with them or
anything kids today are starting to
learn that more as a part of
you know just sort of coming up in
school and that sort of thing but
we didn't so the first step is to say
how am i actually feeling and to be able
to put
a name on on it um it takes practice it
doesn't happen
right away really easily but over time
if you keep doing the practice you'll be
able to say how am i feeling
well i'm feeling sad and i'm feeling
scared and i'm feeling lonely and i'm
feeling hopeful and i'm feeling excited
and you can feel all of these things
together but the first step is to really
know what it is
so um
you want to try again and see if we can
and then find a find a feeling you might
need to wait a minute you might need to
close your eyes you might need to
put your hand on your chest that's like
a nervous system thing that we sometimes
do
and it can help us slow things down a
little bit
is malaise a feeling
uh i feel it's it's hard to it's hard to
explain i guess i guess that's the whole
point of feelings right i know that's
funny i know the biology
i know that feelings are hard to put
into words because they're in our limbic
brain
which doesn't control language uh
so i understand that the biology of why
i struggle to put things into words
um that's not helpful is it uh
the how am i feeling i mean the way i've
been describing it is off my game
uh not myself i mean these are
not affirmative feelings these are i'm
telling you what i'm not
yeah so sometimes we see this when when
we actually
either don't know what we're feeling or
we can't stick with it
we get these like what i call moving
away experiences
so because it feels awful to sit in
sadness or fear or anger or whatever
sometimes we're like uh i'm just gonna
like go over here
i'm gonna push it there and so that's
when we feel malaise that's when we feel
off our games we feel sluggish we don't
want to get out of bed
it's different for everyone some people
are exploding at people
some people are just sort of like
quietly disappearing there's a lot of
different ways this can show up but
that's usually because we're not
like able to sit with that feeling for
whatever reason and for a lot of us
most of us we haven't had this many
challenging feelings all at once and
that's what's so interesting about this
time i mean it's hard for everyone but
it's also kind of equalizing
right single people are having a hard
time parents are having a hard time like
everybody's having their own version of
a hard time
um but like all at once yeah
and i think there's a i mean as you're
talking i'm going through all the things
in my head and they're all
[Music]
un words you know like unmotivated
or frustrated you know or out of control
you know they're all um
the thing there's also an element of
guilt i think because i know that
there is there are people dealing with
way more than i'm dealing with
um and so there's a little bit of guilt
like
that i even feel bad at all you know
um yeah i hear that a lot and because
you know the biology you know that your
body doesn't
compare how you're feeling to other
people and then say oh okay now
now i can feel upset now i can now i can
let it affect me it's like
everybody's experience is their own
experience whether it's
technically super terrible or
technically okay right a lot of us are
technically okay like we're not
living on the street we have food to eat
like we're gonna be okay
but our emotions are are run off of like
a very ancient system in us right so
like
belonging is a big one loneliness is a
big one like
if you get cast out of the tribe
and a lion's gonna eat you that's a
problem
so we're wired to be really upset about
this i hear a lot of people saying like
i'm okay like i see a couple people like
i shouldn't be this upset by this but
but we're supposed to be like this it's
how we stay alive it's how we've stayed
alive for a long time
so how do i find myself again
like i i don't need to be like
rah-rah-rah every day i get that like
that's fine like there's the usual
machinations of you know but how do i
get through this yeah
so i mean i think it's really about
starting to access those feelings a
little bit at a time
getting used to it saying i can handle
it this isn't really that bad
um and getting to the point where we can
tolerate more of these uncomfortable
feelings and then we don't have to do
this
dodging thing like you're saying i have
to find words to put
i have to find those words even if
they're very uncomfortable to admit
yes first you find the words the next
step you do is you actually learn how to
sit with those feelings a little bit
alone or with a coach or with a
therapist or with a friend or whatever
it doesn't really matter
um as long as you feel safe and you can
and you can handle it
and most people think like okay if i'm
gonna get into sad i'm gonna open this
pandora's
box of sadness and i'm gonna fall into
the abyss and that'll be the end of it
right it's just gonna
die alone sad but really what happens is
if we if we go through a process
we can say okay i feel sad i don't like
to feel sad
whatever but i but i feel it and i'm
gonna feel it for a couple of minutes
um and you can actually like decide to
feel sad for a minute
you can set a timer you can practice
feeling sad
um then you can feel sad for a little
longer and a little longer until maybe
you know maybe it only takes a couple
minutes of feeling sad for her to pass
through you maybe you'll feel
again tomorrow maybe you won't i really
like this
i like this idea of giving yourself
permission to feel because i think so
many times i speak for myself you know
if i have
feelings that i would consider negative
or things that pull me back or hold me
down or whatever words you want to use
you know there's the there's the
suppression like
i cannot feel this way or i have to get
over this or
and what i'm denying myself is this the
permission
to just accept the feelings and feel
them and so
what i appreciate is to give that
feeling a name
even it doesn't even if i want to call
it depression it doesn't have to be a
clinical diagnosis i think i think a lot
of people are afraid of those words that
veer into sort of diagnoses myself
included
and give it whatever it's called and say
okay today i'm going to feel
depressed for 20 minutes
and set a timer and i whatever
depression means
i can pull out the ice cream or watch tv
you know sit in bed um i'm allowed to be
depressed for 20 minutes today
yeah yeah and we actually accepted like
two minutes
two minutes even like you can just like
dip your toe in this doesn't have to be
the whole big thing you can just dip
your toe in what does it feel like to
feel
sad what does it feel like to feel
scared you can do a couple minutes here
a couple minutes there
um and rather compartmentalize like you
may have to do
in the military you're able to say hey
like a thing happened today
and i felt terrible okay that's sad i'm
gonna spend a couple minutes on it oh
and i felt frustrated because you can
feel a lot of things at once
right and and so one thing that
really occurs to me is like you're the
optimist guy you're supposed to be
positive you're supposed to be
hopeful you're supposed to be all the
positive emotions so what happens when
the optimist guy
has challenging feelings and maybe isn't
feeling super positive all the time like
i would imagine you have a lot
maybe even more pressure than the
average person to
not show that you're feeling these
things
i yes and no i mean optimism is a bias
for me it's a natural disposition
you know uh and so
i am finding that when my friends are
calling me and saying like a friend
called me the other day and said
you know she's struggling i was like i
was
my old self again like to be in service
to me is the thing that i need the most
and i think one of the things that i'm
struggling with is is i'm
i'm i have fewer opportunities to really
be in service
posting things on social media does not
it's not service you know
but to actually be there with people for
people um
um even if it's something as silly as
just answering questions you know when i
do book club every week
you know i just answer people's
questions i'm i'm so happy
to be in service and i think part of
what is creating my feeling is i'm
disconnected from the thing that brings
me joy which is service
and finding new ways to serve at a
distance and by the way when i say the
distance phone is fine
right but uh but um
yeah so so i don't feel the pressure
that i have to be optimistic all the
time because i've got something to prove
and
it's my brand because i don't want to
fake it you know i also pride myself on
the fact that
you know there's an authenticity to all
of it that that i am who i am
warts and all right and i if i'm always
optimistic that means
somebody that means it's an unrealistic
thing for others to
to aim for it's which is you know no
one's that way all the time
right um well what i found with with um
i i i tend towards optimism too and a
lot of my clients do
what i found is that that means we have
less practice with those difficult
emotions
so it's like it's not that it's pressure
but like that's just the way that we are
so then when we have this experience of
being
in a lot of difficult emotions we're
like we don't this isn't really like our
realm we don't i don't really do sad
like i'm i'm just gonna silver lining
everything
which is fine sometimes but like
i mean you're good at you're good at
being in service and being with people
in how they're feeling like
you clearly have a lot of practice at
that but i wonder how much practice you
have
for yourself in being with those things
the thing that i really appreciate about
this is this idea of practicing emotions
you know which is not not just the bad
ones but the good ones
like for people who are in a bad place
or who struggle with things like
optimism to practice happy today i'm
gonna be happy for two minutes something
good happened
i'm gonna do happy for two minutes or
proud of something i
or i completed and i think i think
that's really fantastic i think that's a
i think that's such great advice
especially for people who
you know um there's lots of income
there's lots of
there's jobs all of these things that
are happening to people um
uh to to practice good as well
you know for me to be okay with you know
unfamiliar
uh emotions i think that's that can be
it can be across the board i just love
this idea of practicing emotions matter
what they are
yeah absolutely i have a client right
now who's been working on joy
because he's really good at finding the
problems and he's built this incredible
company because he can find all the
problems and patch him up
and then now that we're saying well
what's good and what's wonderful and
he's like i don't know and now that he's
been searching for joy and practicing
feeling joy like he's finding it
everywhere so you're totally right it's
it's like
a lot of people come and they say i
don't do emotions i'm not really good at
them or i'm like i really like i feel
comfortable in this zone
and it just means they haven't practiced
some people get practice as kids from
their parents some people get practice
in school some some of us never learned
it so we just have to learn it now and
it's not this mysterious thing it's just
it's another skill that we practice and
it it makes us great leaders and it
makes us great friends and
partners and and all the things
this is so good thank you andrea
yeah yeah you're so good i appreciate it
i'm gonna call you afterwards and
try and tell you some of these emotions
i'll talk to you soon okay take care bye